[Music]  see the crew here again starting to  really getting their first taste of  microgravity  [Music]  this is opening a new era in human space  flight we are taking the first step in a  next generation platform initiative  that's going to bring working living and  research and space to a much broader  and more international audience  [Music]  we're working with a a commercial  company to have them come to our  international space station and we're  learning to work together and figuring  out how to work together and this is  going to be an important step for us  because moving forward we would actually  like to now be able to  buy a ride and time on orbit with the  commercial company to be able to have  them do that  [Music]  there is a lot of  rich people  who want to have in their belts that  they traveled to space and came back  so that is going to be one sector  but for commercial exploitation of space  i think the laws need to come in place  globally